ehi ciao
[Musica]
le donne nel mondo del business così
come in altri settori sono
drammaticamente sotto rappresentate
io ho scelto questo mondo anche se non
ho studiato nel business l'economia ma
traduzione però qualche anno fa quando
mi hanno proposto durante una serata
erasmus un lavoro da business developer
io un po per l'incoscienza un po per
l'alto accettato ma principalmente
perché alla fine del mio percorso di
studi non avevo grandi prospettive
professionali
dopo qualche anno di studi questo è
quello di cui mi occupo ancora tutt'oggi
di international business development
per alcune aziende europee però qualche
anno fa non sapevo nemmeno cosa
significasse il business development
allora ho fatto quello che faccio ogni
volta che sono presa dall'ansia della
minoranza perché non so qualcosa
immagino anche voi e ricerca su google
il fatto è che se ricercate qualsiasi
cosa in ambito business su un qualsiasi
motore di ricerca
quello che vi troverete davanti è il 90
per cento delle volte leggere
declinazioni di un'unica cosa vi faccio
vedere se ad esempio google a te ceo
amministratore delegato
questo è quello che vi troverete davanti
il modello è più o meno uguale abbiamo
un uomo bianco diventa più o meno matura
in giacca e cravatta
loro sono stati per anni per forza di
cose inventori e insegnanti li vedo
tutti i giorni al lavoro sono quelli
estroversi espansivi sicuri di sé che
prendono spazio in una stanza o la
scrivania e poi c'ero io insicura
estremamente timida
non mi piace molto parlare non amo molto
parlare per anni le loro lezioni non
hanno attecchito al cento per cento su
di me e quindi per me è stato molto
facile pensare allora se non riesco a
essere come loro questo mondo forse non
fa per me questo lavoro non fa per me ho
pensato
molte volte di lasciare il mio lavoro
preferendo piuttosto la disoccupazione
ma magari sarete pensando ma quanto è
drammatica ma cosa avranno fatto male
questi businessman stasera vi racconterò
alcuni episodi che mi sono accaduti
realmente e che per quanto vi possano
sembrare assurdi in realtà sono cose che
succedono alle professioniste come me
tutti i giorni ad esempio qualche anno
fa ero presso un'università essere
perché uno dei mercati di cui mi occupo
e quello universitario per incontrare il
rettore come accade spesso sono l'unica
donna nella stanza io mi colleghi ci
mettiamo in riga così che quando il
rettore entra possiamo stringergli la
mano per salutarlo il rettore comincia a
salutare ea stringendo la mano e mi
colleghi alla mia destra
poi arriva a me io gli allungo la mano
per poterlo salutare e lui mi guarda
attraverso come se non esistessi e passa
al prossimo collega lasciandomi con una
mano sospesa nel vuoto è un sorriso da
ebete sulla faccia il fatto è che quando
mi guardate non sono esattamente la
prima cosa che vi viene in mente quando
pensate ai business
se vi chiedessi di pensare dei dei
famosi esempi di imprenditoria
probabilmente vi verrà in mente lui o
magari lui o forse lui l'uomo chiama
alle donne più di chiunque altro
se invece vi chiedessi di pensare a un
film in cui una persona fa un sacco di
soldi grazie al mondo degli affari
sicuramente vi verrà in mente questo qui
però se chiedete a me il miglior film
sull'imprenditoria che abbia mai visto
e questo la storia di una ragazza che
contro ogni pronostico e contro la sua
famiglia mette in piedi in piedi un
impero imprenditoriale in giacca di
pelle gioie un film però le storie vere
spesso sono più belle di quelle che
vediamo al cinema
stasera voglio presentarvi una nuova
idea di imprenditori a lei
sofia amoroso l'agorà boss per
eccellenza l'imprenditrice che noi tutti
dovremmo conoscere sofia ha abbandonato
gli studi superiori e stata licenziata
tantissime volte
rubava raccoglieva cv dei cassonetti per
poter mangiare e ha fondato il suo brand
nesti gale da letto di casa sua da sola
semplicemente raccogliendo accomodando
vestiti usati per poi rivenderli su ebay
oggi un'imprenditrice multimilionaria
anche se la vedete mangiare un back e
l'ho presa da un cassonetto
anche se non ha né giacca e cravatta ma
un cap top il suo brand e racconta di
una donna ribelle fiera sicura della
propria particolarità anche se la
propria particolarità essere una
disadattata una scostumata
fortunatamente abbiamo altri esempi come
quello di sofia esempi di donne che
portano avanti le proprie idee senza
doversi necessariamente piegare un
modello che sembra essere quello
vincente esempi di donne con le trecce
con la gonna con una barca miss che si
occupano di politica in un continente
senza altri presidente donne con storie
di abusi povertà e violenza alle spalle
con situazioni economiche e familiari
disastrose donne non esattamente bianchi
oricchio non esattamente simpatica a
tutti donne col pancione
abbiamo tutti questi esempi straordinari
eppure le donne fanno ancora fatica ad
emergere
torniamo un attimo al mondo del business
appena un manager su quattro è donna e
in italia il 22 per cento delle attività
è a conduzione femminile sul totale ed
esilio meno del 20 per cento sono donne
una donna è molto più facilmente
scavalcata per una promozione da un
collega uomo a parità di competenze o
anche se non ho competenze interiori
qualche anno fa preparavo con il mio
capo meeting che avremmo ottenuto dopo
qualche ora abbiamo discusso lungamente
di quello che lui avrebbe dovuto dire o
fare poi io gli dico io cosa faccio
e lui mi dice sorridi essi carina essere
carino mi esce sempre benissimo
solo che di sorridere quel giorno
proprio non avevo voglia
ho scoperto poi dopo che io ero a quel
medico soltanto per aumentare
visivamente il prestigio del mio capo
siamo convinti di questa idea per cui le
donne sono quegli esseri obbedienti
servizievoli efficienti per tutti ma
senza fare rumore
però le donne ci possono ispirare con le
loro storie ribelli perché da sempre
sono coloro che cambiano il modo di fare
le cose
il modo in cui si sono sempre fatte vi
potete lasciarvi ispirare da storie di
donne si sa che voi abbiate donne che
diventano icone pop cantando canzoni
anche un po blasfeme si sa che voi
abbiate dei modelli un po più
tradizionali
la madonna è una delle figure più
ribelli che abbiamo nella nostra cultura
ed è il motivo per cui il cristianesimo
è una delle religioni più diffuse al
mondo oggi una ragazza di 16 anni che
prende da solo la decisione è enorme
come quella di una gravidanza difficile
da giustificare all'interno del suo
contesto socio economico che prima di
accettare una decisione presa da dio
dice all'arcangelo aspetta un attimo
parliamo prima di quello che mi stai
chiedendo che non chiede autorizzazione
né al padre nella madre né al futuro
sposo che decide di intraprendere da
sola è incinta un viaggio lungo mesi
prendere trovare suo cugino che è
incinta e sempre nella bibbia c'è
un'altra storia che amo particolarmente
che è la parabola della dramma perduta
c'è una donna che ha dieci grammi 10
monete e ne perde una in casa propria è
disperata perché la cerca ovunque non
riesce a trovarla
poi a fine la ritrova e per festeggiare
questa buona notizia decide di invitare
le amiche a casa sua per per fare una
festa abbiamo quella che viene definita
una donna non una moglie una figlia non
una madre che gestisce da sola le
proprie finanze e che organizza feste a
casa propria con le sue amiche per una
buona notizia finanziaria se volete
prove storiche dal fatto che le donne si
occupano da sempre di soldi e di
gestione finanziaria le troverete
ovunque nei libri o nei musei loro ad
esempio le trovate a rex siano di
amsterdam sono delle fantastiche donne
da fare che contano soldi sul tavolo i
segni sono ovunque basta guardare un po
più attentamente
eppure le donne sono ancora sotto
rappresentate nel business
infatti nel 2010 durante il suo the talk
sheryl sandberg disse non sarà la mia
generazione ad aumentare il numero delle
donne al vertice
spero nelle prossime e la nostra siamo
noi a doverci riprendere quello spazio
come possiamo farlo ribellando c'è la
dittatura di giacca e cravatta in che
modo
noi siamo ancora le apri pista siamo
ancora alle ribelli e in quanto tale
purtroppo è ancora possibile ignorarci
ho sperimentato tante volte il fatto è
che una professionista brava e
facilmente facilmente ignorabile ma è
impossibile non notare una
professionista straordinaria unica che
ottiene risultati in modi mai visti
prima
la straordinarietà sta nel fatto di
chiedersi cos'è che mi rappresenta
meglio cos'è che mi rende speciale cosa
mi fa sentire bene
prendete quella particolarità spingetelo
al massimo e usatela ogni giorno nella
vostra vita quotidiana ma soprattutto
nel vostro mestiere così da diventare
straordinarie in quella cosa che avete
solo voi in quella cosa che vi rende
insostituibile in quella combinazioni di
peculiarità che rende più colorato un
posto altrimenti fatto da i soliti
completi blu con la camicia bianca
se siete delle avvocatesse potete essere
straordinari nella negoziazione
se siete delle psicologhe potete essere
campionesse di empatia
se siete delle birraie potete essere più
grandi esperte di luppolo al mondo la
straordinarietà ci permette di diventare
visibili anche più refrattari anche chi
non volete vedere che i business anselmi
niele funzionano e bene
la straordinarietà ci permette di
diventare di aumentare quella massa
critica che poi permette il cambiamento
del modello corrente come si ottiene più
velocemente la massa critica attraverso
la collaborazione invece che la lotta i
numeri di prima ci dicono che le donne
sono ancora la minoranza ma siamo il
gruppo più popoloso di escluse e la
forza della minoranza sta nella coesione
del gruppo
ogni volta che abbiamo la possibilità di
metterci insieme di allearci insieme ad
altre donne facciamolo così che nessuno
di noi potrà cadere perché se fallisce
un uomo fallisce un individuo ma se
fallisce una donna purtroppo fallisce
ancora tutta la categoria
abbiamo una responsabilità economica e
sociale di attuare un cambiamento del
genere economica perché ad esempio nelle
aziende dove lavorano più donne
il fatturato è in media più alto del 20
per cento quindi anche gli uomini
guadagneranno di più e sociale perché
donne più ricche sono donne più libere
con famiglie più benestanti dove i figli
hanno più possibilità e in generale la
società tutta la società sarà più
prospera sarà una società basata su un
modello variegato in cui il modello
vincente non è soltanto un unico solo
modello di business street un modello
brigato è un modello inclusivo e non
esclusivo ma inclusivo non soltanto per
le donne ma per tutti coloro che non
ricadono all'interno di quelle linee
guida imposte da chi ha il potere in
mano in quel momento
un modello che non esita a denigrare che
ai margini e un modello che non esiterà
a schiacciare buttare come una lattina
vecchia chiunque non si sia conquistato
con le unghie e con i denti e anche con
la cattiveria un po sola in cima ma è
anche un modello pochi efficienza che
funziona male perché sta negando a se
stesso e la spinta che apporterebbero
tutti gli esclusi tutti quanti noi
abbiamo qualcosa da offrire se siamo
messi nelle condizioni di farlo se
invitiamo verso il centro che adesso
releghiamo le periferie
se ci conquistiamo quello spazio
economico ci riconquisteremo anche quel
quel potere politico sociale e culturale
che oggi puntualmente ci viene sottratto
ci viene negato cosa possiamo fare tutti
quanti noi oggi per muoverci in quella
direzione
se siete uomini potete sostenere le
donne in cui credete sostenendo le loro
idee e le loro strategie
includendo le quando le vedete escluse
ma la cosa più importante che potete
fare è investire nelle donne in cui
credete assumendole dando loro lo
stipendio che dovreste un uomo comprando
e investendo nelle loro attività se
credete in un modello più inclusivo se
vi sentite degli uomini illuminati siate
il buon esempio per chi ancora non vede
la luce e noi donne cosa possiamo fare a
partire da oggi possiamo essere
straordinarie ma senza metterci addosso
quella pressione schiacciante di essere
perfette io ad esempio a stasera non ho
preteso di essere la speaker migliore
del mondo
non sarò nemmeno la migliore spiegare a
questo evento e in generale nella vita
ho un sacco di difetti un sacco di tic
sono estremamente timida a volte sono
socialmente imbarazzante però quando
faccio business development non mi ferma
nessuno
ogni giorno accetto la mia stranezza e
rime diversità respingo al massimo per
raggiungere la straordinarietà del mio
mestiere raccogliendo alleate sono mia
strada
condividendo la mia storia non vi
vogliamo diverse da come siete
ma siate voi stesse all'ennesima potenza
soltanto così potrete anche voi
contribuire all'aumento di quella massa
critica che ci permette di cambiare il
modello corrente potrebbe succedervi di
sentirvi stanche abbattute tristi
confuse e normale soprattutto tra le
ribelli che combattono in prima fila vi
chiedo un'altra cosa
non lasciate il campo di battaglia e
chiedete supporto chiedete supporto alle
vostre amiche alle vostre colleghe a
vostra madre ha delle strane ammessa
sera
ogni volta che avrete la tentazione di
fermarvi perché avete incontrato degli
ostacoli lungo la vostra strada
abbiate il coraggio di insistere e di
chiedere a supporto fatelo per voi
stesse e per tutti noi siamo nelle
vostre mani
grazie ciao
[Musica]